nous les étudiants guadeloupéens et
martiniquais nous retrouvons dans une
situation assez spéciale depuis le début
de la pandémie
donc c'est à dire fin mars en effet la
seule compagnie qui opérait les liaisons
entre les deux îles et montréal les a
suspendus depuis le 25 janvier vraiment
un billet d'avion pour le retourner en
guadeloupe le 25 mars qui a été annulé
écologiquement et moralement c'est
compliqué car on se rend compte qu'on
n'est pas soutenue à part par un comité
de parents qui ont été organisées pour
notre rapatriement mais l'état ne fait
rien pour nous on est considérés on ne
se sent pas considérés comme des
citoyens français tomer sisley dyson qui
peuvent tous les jours rentrer chez eux
par vol direct
moralement c'est compliqué car on est
enfermé dans des appartements loin de
notre famille j'aurais préféré être avec
mes parents dans un contexte où le co
vie devient de plus en plus sévères à
montréal on a peur d'être contaminés
quand on est dans la rue quand on fait
des courses ont tout le monde s'éloigne
tout le monde se regarde bizarrement on
n'est pas dans une ambiance chaloupés la
situation qui se pose est que s'envolent
vers la martinique elle a valu que nous
sommes bloqués ici
la seule solution qui s'offre à nous
serait de passer par la métropole ce qui
nous ferait faire de quarantaine payer
deux billets d'avion et surtout nous
mettre plus à risque de contracter le
virus
quand on s'est rendu compte que ça
allait vraiment compliqué de rentrer
chez nous car et un canada ne sais c'est
d'annuler nos vols donc nous avons
commencé à envoyer des mails et des
lettres aux différentes instances et on
s'est rendu compte que l'état nous
laisse pour compte et nous dit de nous
débrouiller par nous mêmes c'est à dire
de passer par paris dont 2 cumulé de vol
de huit heures d'avion ainsi que des
billets à des prix exorbitants soit un
prix de 1000 euros nous sommes bloqués
ici sans avoir la possibilité de rentrer
auprès de nos proches dans des
situations délicates pour certains déjà
sur le plan financier
ne pouvant
pas travailler vu que tout est fermé ici
sur le plan psychologique
n'ayant aucune information officielle
concernant notre retour
pour ma part je suis en train de refaire
mes papiers d'immigration pour étudier
ici faut absolument que je rentre j'ai
la chance d'avoir de vivre en
appartement et nos résidences
universitaires alors qu'elles ont fermé
présentement nous sommes dans une
situation d'inquiétude de doute et
surtout d'incertitude quant à notre
retour en martinique
on ne sait pas porter ce combat quand
est ce que l'on ne pas pouvoir partir
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir revoir nos
proches et ça devient de plus en plus
lourd à supporter pour le moral